peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on connaît maintenant les tristes
conséquences du drame d'alger 25 mar 140
blessés depuis le matin un important
service d'ordre était en place dans la
ville jusqu alors relativement calme
mais l'après midi la foule que des
tracts avaient appelé à manifester
commencé à édifier des barricades
[Applaudissements]
des camions militaires munis de haut
parleurs circulait répétant les appels
au calme
à mesure que les heures passaient la
tension augmentait des groupes venus de
bab el oued et d'autres qui descendait
la rue michelet se trouvaient réunis
pour prendre ensemble le chemin du
monument aux mains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et dans cette foule l'excitation grandit
c'est dr devenait inévitable avec le
service d'ordre
[Applaudissements]
dans ce climat de fièvre ou trop de
mains serrées des armes des coups de feu
avaient retenti quelques minutes plus
tard c'était le drame
au matin les boutiques sont restées
fermées dans un large périmètre autour
du bastion établi par les émeutiers au
coeur d'alger
derrière les barricades faites de pavés
arrachés à la rue au dessus desquels se
gonfle un drapeau taché de sang les
insurgés se sont renforcés pendant que
le pc d'ortiz se transformer en
blockhaus
alger cependant est resté calme toute la
journée autour du bastion le long des
barricades la vie continue et peut être
était ce leur de réflexion où chacun
pouvait penser aux paroles du général de
gaulle l'émeute qui vient d'être
déclenchée d'un mauvais coup porté à la
france
[Musique]
pour gagner le rallye de monte carlo il
faut être prévoyant pour réaliser une
bonne performance il faut que la voiture
soit bien chaussés autrement dit le
problème essentiel qui se posent aux
concurrents c'est le problème des pneus
pour affronter neige et verglas en toute
sécurité
les allemands choqué molle sur mercedes
de 120 l'ont parfaitement compris
en quittant varsovie ils sont sans
inquiétude et ils ont parfaitement
raison puisqu'ils vont gagner le rallye
[Musique]
et les difficultés commencent
la neige du verglas de la pluie rien
n'était pas remis aux pilotes et aux
voitures
[Musique]
pas le temps évidemment d'admirer le
paysage la moindre faute d'inattention
et c'est l'embardée
cette partie du parcours ressemble plus
à une course de bobsleigh et qu'à une
épreuve d'automobiles
on aurait pu s'attendre à une arrivée
ensoleillée monte-carl et bien non le
ciel aig
ce qui n'a pas empêché les vainqueurs de
se congratuler avec chaleur
salon international des scream à part ça
lui des fleurettistes
[Applaudissements]
et début des éliminatoires
allez
[Applaudissements]
la finale opposait que ce champion
olympique christian d'oriola à droite
aux britanniques
hoskins
[Applaudissements]
d'oriola a prouvé qu'ils se tuent mais
enfin au fleuret électrique en battant
nettement son adversaire
[Musique]
quel roman que ma vie aurait-il pu dire
lui aussi quelle aventure en effet que
celle de ce fils de famille bourgeoise
né rue notre dame de lorette devenu
boursiers et boursiers heureux en
affaire puisqu'ils gagnent en une seule
année la valeur de 40 millions de francs
anciens et qui tout à coup abandonne
famille situation fortune pour se
consacrer tout entier à la passion de
peindre qui l'a saisie il a 35 ans il
s'installe dans un atelier de
montparnasse
encore aujourd'hui occupé par un pacte
sa femme et ses enfants sont partis
vivre loin au danemark
il est seul avec son chevalet ses
pinceaux et cette passion qu'ils
entraient
pour l'heure ils essaient de voir clair
en lui-même à travers manet dont ils
copient l'olympia et coraux dont
l'influencé visible dans les oeuvres de
cette époque
et puis il rompt avec tous là encore il
se retire en bretagne à pont-aven c'est
là dans ce monde nostalgiques se met de
calvaire au réalisme naïf qu'il trouvera
sa libération
s'il se met à vivre à la mode du pays
vivent avec les matelots et les paysans
ils découvrent en même temps par les
fenêtre de son atelier
cette vérité intérieure du sujet pour
laquelle la nature n'est qu'un simple
support librement utiliser et non pas un
modèle absolu
c'est alors qu'il pense aux portraits où
son visage a pris l'aspect puissant et
tragique qu'il gardera désormais et
qu'ils accumulent au long des chemins
creux devant les chaînes tordu et les
rochers de la côte
ses peintures ou rampante avec
l'impressionnisme il s'affirme l'un des
promoteurs d'un mouvement dont la
formule est essentielle est la suivante
vêtir l'idée d'une forme sensible le
peintre ne vise plus la représentation
directe du monde extérieur mais la
suggestion de ses rêves ou de ses
pensées par l'allusion de la forme et de
la couleur
[Musique]
et puis c'est arles épisode rapid mais
qui marquera dans sa vie comme dans
celle de van gogh
ils sont venus ensemble ils se
rencontrent tous les jours ils discutent
autour des verts ou l'absinthe à la
couleur des rêves mais l'absinthe peut
avoir aussi la couleur du crime et de la
folie et van gogh manque d' assassiner
google
toutefois le séjour darleux si court
soit il a découvert à beugin quelque
chose aux alice quand on se promène les
arlésiennes
il a senti l'appel des terres de soleil
il vend tout ce qu'il a avec les dix
mille francs qu'il a réunis il part pour
tahiti à la recherche d'un monde simple
où la vie est heureux il y passera une
dizaine d'années couper d'un retour en
france motivés par ces éternels soucis
d'argent
[Musique]
à doha
dans ces paysages sans passion au milieu
de ces maori aux moeurs facile mais au
passé mystérieux il n'a quand même pas
trouver la paix il se débat dans les
affres les délires de son génie il y
meurt en 1903 de misère et de maladie il
n'a pas quitté les rivages de la petite
île d'hiva oa la houle du pacifique et
les palmes d'océanie perce toujours son
sommeil sans doute sa mort at elle été
pleuré par les chants traditionnels
d'une population qui lui avait donné son
amitié sans doute voit-on encore passer
auprès de sa tombe
les personnages qui hantent les toiles
où s'affirme l'expression de sa réussite
définitive dans le monde de l'art
universel
l'exposition qui vient de s'ouvrir à
paris le pur
[Musique]
et
on a débattu on débat encore sur
l'importance pictural de gauguin chef
d'école ou non promoteur d'une
esthétique à laquelle se rallient le
monde moderne ou monstres solitaire
question mais il reste dans le nom de
gauguin pour le vertige de sa couleur ou
pour l'accent passionné de sa vocation
ou pour le style dramatique de sa vie
une extraordinaire fascination
[Musique]